um so the problem i hope to postulate to
you all is that generic recommendations
are reasonably low efficacy I mean it's
not always so but I mean but they're
typically not not great and kind of in
in the way that I feel like a lot of
systems recommend things to me it's it's
like throwing things out there like hey
people might like this and so the
proposed solution on the other hand is
to leverage um what we know about users
what we know about how groups may be
connected and and by leveraging their
relationships to to really provide
something interesting to the users and
so and when I say it's all about
relationships i actually may install
about data relationships meaning how
were things connected so new for j is a
graph database that leverages something
we call a property graph model and what
that simply means is we use edges and
vertices or in our nomenclature note
nodes and relationships nodes will just
simply be objects in your graph that
have a unique identity they can be
labeled to create sub graphs or describe
groups and they can be enriched with you
know 0 to n key value pairs and you can
store any of the job of primitives is
these key value pairs relationships to
think of it in a in the way we speak it
could be the verbs between these
entities and those can also be enriched
with with key value pairs or properties
be kind of thing of these is the adverbs
to have things or are functioning so for
example up here we can see the story of
Annie and van and you can see these are
directed relationships and this is
important when considering things like
well den loves Annie Annie only only
like Stan and maybe we can look at the
story where you know Dan is living with
Annie he's he's borrowing a nice car and
so we really kind of inspect a little
bit about the story behind our data and
hopefully very clear and apparent way
and so something I want to highlight is
this is actually how need for just
stores the information on disk we have a
node store and edit
store and the reason why this is this is
profoundly powerful is it allows
operations to be done rather than
through index lookups but through
pointer arithmetic and that allows you
to an operating on really really large
data sets you see a flat response time
for forgiving types of queries and to
introduce our data set I'm so how many
years all know to meetup is yeah right
we're geeky developers yes anyone not
know okay so I meetup is is a website
that essentially facilitates the
attendance of get togethers and the
entire motivation for their their
platform is to encourage people to get
together and learn and do of interesting
things and as we're finished the way
they make money is by getting people to
attend these groups and so these
recommendations are very important for
for the profitability of the other
platform and so meetup coms
recommendations take a few different
forms it's kind of the the typical
people who went to this meetup are
interested in this meetup are also in
just simply just suggestions of saying
hey keV you're part of you know San
Francisco they did a science you may
want to go to your tech connectors big
data conference um as well as sending
you emails and say hey by the way these
are some events they're coming up that
the kind of fit into your profile what
are you doing this afternoon and then
also moving through their calendar at
you know what I see what's going on this
evening they'll say oh at six-thirty
there are five different events how do
we rank and sort those things to say
kevin's probably more more interested in
one thing versus another and so there's
several different recommendation queries
we're going to try and walk through
today we're going to look at groups to
join topics to follow and events to
attend and we're going to take this from
the perspective of a meetup com user
though you could look at this from the
other side if you wanted to shoot
backwards work that the system see how
do I actually as a business or group get
myself to the top of these results and
of course you know this is not likely
or underlying data set but the hope is
to introduce some concepts that provide
you with with a good foundation for
applying this to whatever it is you
you're actually working on and so that
the data we grabbed is from the meetup
API it's actually very very very rich
API and we can grab quite a few
different things out of it and so
hopefully to make this hyperlocal we
crawl the the chicago meetup groups grab
some of the big data events some of the
outdoorsy things some of the social
networking events and hopefully this
makes things very interesting um so if
we're just kind of inspecting a normal
meetup page um these are the different
pieces of information on me we may want
to grab on do to look at and so we're
going to have you know groups the
members of those groups the events these
groups are hosting on the topics that
these groups you're talking about that
where they are is incredibly important
then also you know time I mean maybe I
can't go to 1030am event but really in
at four o'clock i'm ready to get out of
the office um and so if we were to look
at things like oh and as a member of the
outdoorsy entrepreneur should meet up I
want to find similar meetup groups so
that I can join them and so um to look
at kind of what may make these groups
similar we often will look at that the
things that they that they'd like to
talk about the topics that they they
discuss and we can use shared topics as
a proxy for similarity this basically
content filtering we're going to say
well near for j is all about being open
source and data science london is also
all about being open source maybe those
groups are fairly similar and people are
interested in one may be interested in
another and so I show this slide again
because now we're reaction they start
getting into the browser actually you're
writing a little bit of code is everyone
downloading 4j that wants to yeah good
and so a great grass Batman let's go to
the browser so to start neo4j simply
navigate into wherever you've downloaded
or stored it
and then is you know felt / been you
know for J space start neo4j hopefully
we ready by the time I click over the
next window and so this is the NIA forge
a browser it's a query workbench for you
to test it and look at okay are the
queries i'm entering actually
interactive the data in which i hope
though of course there's there's a shot
but for more traditional interaction
methods and so um the guide that that
we're going to be walking through then
is that readable mostly so just colon
play HTTP colon slash slash guides neo4j
com /hi data CH I I mean you can leave
off the the file portion that's for me
in case there's bad internet in case so
I stored the files locally but so this
would be the correct guide for you guys
well everybody there yeah oh and so a
quick you know 30 second tour of how to
interact with a browser got the browser
up here we have our wonderful query
entry point to add additional lines
shift enter allows you to scroll up and
down once you've done shift enter
command enter will execute the query or
you can guys click up here on this
wonderfully designed start button if you
need to cycle through previous queries
command up will allow you to cycle
through everything that you've been
typing in and if that if you're going
trying to go you know way way way way
back I'm colon history would be a manner
to pull up all the queries that you've
executed over here on the Left we have a
little bit of information about our
database we're starting fresh together
so i have no note labels in our database
and their relationship types no property
keys over here i have some saved strips
because you live coding is terrifying
and also
some quick links to documentation so
let's let's get started so let's go and
start by clicking on the the recommended
groups by topic and so so this is the
the data model that we're going to be
working against for at least this
initial portion we're simply going to be
looking at groups will have a
relationship to a topic and by the way
we're going to that the words inside the
bubbles will be considered labels in
this case you know if a group shares a
topic with another group are they
similar and you know we will rank their
similarity by the more shared topics
that they have and so the the way in
which we're going to get data into neo4j
is we're going to use something called
the load csv tool it's a transactional
ETL tool that will allow any for Jay to
grab a flat file interpret and transform
it hopefully into a reasonable graph
model that we can work against so go
ahead and click this first prompt should
you click the gray box it'll it'll
render it up here and that in the quarry
bar and so we can actually kind of look
at what what is the the type of data
that we're pulling in and so to break
down this is queer little bit or say
we're calling that the load csv tool
we're saying we have a CSV with headers
meaning at the top of the column is some
sort of title for what that information
is from and then we provide it with a
location these can be other local files
or URL I'm using local files just for
expediency you guys will see a URL is
pointing to a CSV hosted on the Internet
we're aliasing it as a row such is a for
each where the up for each row do XY and
z and now we're just saying oh just
return me that those rows we want to
take a quick look and only show me ten I
don't want to look at the entirety of
that CSV and so you may see something
like this where we have maybe the first
entry in our CSV is a a meetup group
called the Evanston Sherman make that
little bigger the
Sherman Avenue 900 block neighbors the
organizers name is Martin Ren key and we
have a bit more of information the one
thing to take a quick look as we have an
ID value here that we're going to be
using to grab on do and so by the way
too if you end up filling up your your
browser with too much stuff just click
on these X's clears them out for you I'm
if you're real frustrated colon clear
will get rid of everything so we click
along a little further let's actually
import some data so we're going to say
load CSP with headers from this location
I'm alias that as row we're going to do
merge which means ensure this thing
exists so it's a match or create and
we're going to do is Narcy will ensure
that this group exists so this this
colon group is the label we're working
with and make sure that the group a
group exists of this ID and we're
describing this row ID value and so
we're gonna say on create set all of
these good things and we'd also append
this and say you know um on match set
some other property if we do searches on
match set you know group dot saw matt
meant it
the / file is if you had them stored in
a local directory um so the question was
I'm having a little trouble getting to
the correct data set so if you're seeing
this file colon slash slash slash
location you entered in the wrong
browser guide that's my fault I I did I
was afraid of the internet so I stored
the files locally on my laptop it so I
gave these these local locations if you
guys don't or if you guys want to to
code along i would use this guide but
without the the ford / files I'm so this
would be the correct address to hit to
actually access this guide um is anyone
else having similar troubles we all good
awesome so I should have been a little
more clear yeah give a quick second cool
so it's actually in its import a little
bit of data so while that's running me
and talk about the next thing and so
we're going to go through and so for
example I've ended up creating you know
over a thousand labels thousand nodes we
set five thousand properties and we're
actually just going to keep going
through this and still we're actually
look at the group's underscore topic CSV
now and so what we're wanting to do now
is look at what do they do we have you
know if you remember our data model we
have the different groups we created now
we're creating that Center know those
those different types of topics and so
for example we have a group is tied to a
topic called neighbors and so we'll go
ahead and create that
[Music]
and so we can do is we actually inspect
that say okay did did these things that
I'm trying to import actually do what I
wanted them to or down actually get that
data incorrectly oh that's still loading
if you guys are pulling these over the
internet there moderately sized file so
it may take a little bit of time let's
now let's take another look so we
actually were able to get them so we
have topics with a topic ID and a topic
name if we wanted to return like a a
pretty picture of what these topics look
like we get a little bit more of a
visual representation and asked return
instead of a given property on their own
you know t name or instead saying well
actually if we j return me the complete
node and we had some cool pictures and
you'll notice though we don't have any
relationships branching off of them
right these are just a little islands
and I on our datastore and so the the
next step is going to be actually
connecting the the groups and topics and
so we're going to do is we actually end
up grabbing the group ID row within a
CSV and then using that as a handle to
say okay this group is is tied to this
tag so beforehand though we're going to
create some indexes and I'm actually
going to give you guys a quick note on
on how index is working here for Jade
they slightly vary from from the
relational world and though if we wanted
to see what what indexes were active now
it's L we've created an index on nodes
that are labeled group on the ID
property and on topics that are labeled
or on nodes that are labeled topic they
also have an ID property that has been
indexed so a come on
so a quick note on on on constraints
inside neo4j there there are two types
or two and a half types of constraints
inside neo4j one is a uniqueness
constraint which essentially just
ensures uniqueness upon creating an
Ekans constraint we auto index that
property and these are always going to
be paired against a label and a given
property on a node so the basic syntax
for this is create constraint on some
identify or T this could be any variable
which its self referential within the
query and grab the the topic labeled
nodes and then assert that t ID is
unique so assert that some property on
top on on the topic nodes called ID is
unique if we're not as concerned about
uniqueness but simply just want a handle
to mid allows for fast lookups we just
created a generic index again I'll me
these label property pairs so it simply
be create index on colon group this
represents the label we're working with
and then the properties is name and also
so there are a couple of functions
within neo4j or keywords that are also
index back back exactly qualities will
be starts with contains and ends with
these are just ring operators to find if
a you know a given property starts with
a string or contains a string etc range
searches will also the index back back
and then I'm existence / non-existence
checks as well so typically at least for
me when I when I first started working
with Nia my first was I will index
everything which it comes from electro
that totally makes sense if you're
essentially grabbing you know doing a
scan grabbing things say okay it matches
up here doing a scan grab that matches
up there and you know my results that is
simply just the the aggregate of all
those things that all matched on on
joins um those indexes are very very
very helpful though they cost low Space
Storage it makes things go quick which
is important on the other hand neo4j is
not concerned with indexing to the same
extent
instead we're simply indexing the are
the the property that we want to find
for the starting points in our traversal
so if we're to think of you know
identifying user groups we may want to
to create a a property on an index on a
given property that we're going to be
searching on but if we have like
intermediate traversals we don't really
care about the properties on there
because those won't be accessed until
they're called at the very end of the
query and hopefully at that point we
filtered down from you know the ocean of
our data set like you know fairly
reasonable size bucket um so back to it
back to the browser by the way any
questions so far yes no maybe so cool so
it's actually connect these groups and
so the reason why we wanted to index
those properties was because we're
actually doing some matches here to say
well you know grab these topics within
our CSV rose and you match them with the
actual topics that exist our database
now go and grab these groups and you
know identify the ones that match up
with that that Rowan or CSV and find
that the groups that actually just in
our database and then say okay now we
found that they're on they match go
ahead and tie them together and so will
you know let's check let's make sure we
do we make some graphi things and the
answer is yes we have pictures now this
this is what Nia fridge is all about
making pretty pictures and as a side
tangent you can totally make your
pictures more or less pretty depending
on your preferences you make the notes
bigger making that smaller you change
the way we display them um this is not
paramount to your success as any of her
jdeveloper um but I mean have a little
fun with it and so we see for example
the evanston sherman group that we're
talking about earlier has you know
several topics branching off of it where
you know it's a part of the neighbors
topic possess a topic of neighbors
neighborhood fun times local issues new
to area etc and we're going to
essentially find out okay well what what
are the shared topics between
Sherman neighborhood watch group and you
know anything else and so again more
index is right because we're going to be
searching on these things where we're
actually I'm going to be looking up
groups by their name I'm going to be
looking up topics by their name and then
i'll be using those as the starting
points for these recommendation
traversals and so this command may not
work for you guys you have to install
it's called a POC it's a awesome
procedures on cipher is the acronym and
if you guys are matrix fans you also
know that a POC was a kind of the hacky
character within within the matrix and
it's exactly what we've done here Nia
Jay has a a concept of stored procedures
um and I earnestly say this is true like
my favorite feature in the past two
years I denier for Jay and what it does
is it allows you to write you know in
any JV a JVM language typically Java a
stored procedure that you can then you
know drop in an ear for jay is a plug-in
and then call from the same endpoint but
you hit cypher with and do some really
interesting and complex traversals while
still having the ease of use and the
declarative pneus of cipher for the
intermediate steps and so we're going to
do here is we're going to call actually
this is not even in a pot Graham I'm all
I'm off on a tangent what's where I
should call it just the index is here to
look at what indexes are live and what
are they what are they on and so for
example we have indexes on group group
ID group name topic ID and topic name
and they're all in line right we've
we've done what we hope to do and so now
I invite you all to explore the graph
with me for those who know a little bit
of cipher nay let's try and find you
know what is the most popular topic what
topic has the most groups associated
with it spend like 15 seconds though if
you guys are vastly impatient you just
click next and see the answers the other
questions were asking is which group was
created most recently we have a time
stamp on these groups and then how many
groups we have been running for greater
than four years we're using
millisecond since epoch so much is
easier to operate on so skipping ahead
this is the way we would figure out what
the most popular groups are we're
matching a very very generic
relationship pattern here of saying
match me you know a topic what has a
relationship called has topic and then
any node hanging off their we're not
being specific and then we're simply
going to to count as count the number of
instances there and for relational
developers may be looking at what you've
counted where is the group by there's an
implicit group by on on this on this
pattern that we're matching and so let's
order by the count descending and this
would be the result set so it appears
that social is the most popular and a CP
couple people squinting so if your
social is the most popular topic so from
networking is next it seems like if
you're new and lonely you're drawn meet
up and I don't know if that says about
me as a person also if you're an
entrepreneur you are both you know it's
very very deeply interested in meetup
groups so we move on to the next
question you know which group was
created most recently um we're simply
just ordering by the this created
timestamp and so it turns out for one
more more row e format it was created at
that time stamp and it is the Ignite
executive marketing workshop I'm estate
is about a week old it's just probably a
new meetup since then but as of a week
ago and the last one is is you know how
many groups is running for the past four
years so you know we're assuming no leap
years were you know I'm not super
accurate so over four years 365 days 24
hours a day 60 minutes an hour I'm 60
seconds in a minute and then a thousand
milliseconds in a second and their words
aliasing that as four years and then
we're going to match groups that were
created at a time that is greater than
four years ago
and so the women entrepreneurs secrets
of success has been running in Chicago
for greater than four years
asian-american Chicago network Windy
City skaters et cetera et cetera and so
so does this codes actually stolen from
from mark Needham whose part of the near
future London users group obviously you
know if we were to search for groups are
some of the London users group i assume
is not in chicago we're actually getting
no results but last night i cheated and
chose a group that i thought was really
interesting which is the outdoorsy
entrepreneurs networking and support
group and so to kind of talk about this
this query we're trying to execute is
we're saying match meaning neo4j find me
this pattern in my data and we're saying
find me a group that's called near the
outdoorsy entrepreneurs networking and
support group that has a relationship to
any given topic and if you notice topic
here simply an identifier we didn't
choose to say oh it's you know we didn't
say be very specific only you know
groups that are related to an actual
topic node we're making the assumption
that things that have a relation called
has topic are indeed topics and switch
gave it a generic identifier we could
you know we call it t we call it middle
thing these are all independent of or
these can be anything you want they're
simply just a handle to refer to within
the query and I so for example were here
we're saying okay match me and grab all
the other groups that are also attached
that topic node that the outdoorsy
entrepreneurs network is also tied to
our sink simply return me the other
groups name show me the count of shared
topics between the meeting so we have
our outdoorsy entrepreneurs we have
these other groups and simply just count
up the number of in between topics they
share and simply order them by that so
if they share more topics hopefully I'm
more interested in them and to go and
return me there
things and so apparently if I'm into
this group I groups that are very
similar to it would be you know a
thousand places to see before you die
Chicago backpackers great outdoors and
survival apparently it seems that
entrepreneurship is less of a compar to
this then the outdoorsy adventure pneus
but yeah that is what it is that's how
the group is self-described and so the
next step is actually going to be doing
something a little more sophisticated
this where we're Python makes neo4j much
more interesting we're going to do a
community detection algorithm to
actually see what groups kind of fall
into interesting clicks or groups so if
you guys click on the next portion of
the guide what we're going to be doing
is we're going to not only find
similarity between based on topics but
actually trying to find natural groups
that form and it into to a reasonable
chunk and so we're going to use a supra
note book use a little bit of I graph
and then be neo4j actually it's not the
official name for J Python driver but is
written by a gentleman named Nigel small
who actually also works at neo and it is
so incredibly beautifully documented and
is so wonderfully functional that I
encourage you guys play with it shooting
I about Nigel thank you note this is his
baby and it's wonderful um so get
started I'm actuated the my Jupiter
notebook open but so this is make it
bigger bigger is better so we're going
to go through and I'm actually after
this talk I'll send you guys that this
this notebook and so one were just
ensuring hey you make sure that I
actually a Python you installed I do and
so if we were essentially more here's to
show the basic format of how you'd pass
cypher into the the Pioneer driver
answer assume is saying and clear query
equals and then a string that contains a
cipher query
and then just show me these this result
and so for example we're simply saying
you find me groups that have a topic
that contains Python um and I mean pie
dish you like there are more Python
groups there right and I'm hoping that
this was simply just my API crawl just
didn't didn't do as much as I hoped it
did so right there there lots of meetup
groups here yes yes no quiet alright and
so we're actually to calculate topic
similarity and so you know obviously we
understand how to execute queries in
cypher now at least at a high level so
we're going to do is one you make sure
we have I graph installed and so what
we're going to do is we're going to find
all pairs of topics and then work a
member of common groups there and then
we'll use that as a weight in our in our
similarity calculations it's kinda what
we did originally we're said group 1
group 2 count how many are similar and
so we see that the the topic of sorry if
we're in your topic group topic the top
of social networking Co appears with a
the topic of social 175 times in our
data set the topic of social co appears
with with new in town 173 times and so
what we want to do is kind of wrap that
output in a graph and then pass that to
i graph so we've instantiated i graph
and let's actually um just do some
cluster detection so it's actually
regent large datasets this may take a
second I'm so we've actually identified
81 clusters in our in our in our in our
data set and actually how many how many
different topics do we have let's find
out for curiosity sake
spellings helpful so out of the 2709
topics we have we've actually were able
to chunk them down by 81 natural groups
and so we'd actually like to do is take
so we've identified these 81 clicks and
actually so a little bit about the the
outcome algorithm we used I'm called
walk trap essentially the the hope is
for you start with each topic will start
as its own individual group and we're
simply going to do is grab the the
adjacent relationships and essentially
trying to minimize the amount of
variance or minimize the amount of
outgoing relationships from that from
that group and so such a little ad say
okay you know oh we added more more
outgoing relations let's bring it back
one and I'm so sensually it allows you
to identify natural chunks of nodes
within your data set and so we're going
to write a cipher query that takes the
results of our community detection
algorithm and write the results back to
near for jay's we're using Python and I
graph to enrich our data set to do some
interesting community detection and then
saying okay to make that operational on
let's actually pass that back into our
database oh god do things in order so
first we actually need to find these
groups so for example and in group 0 we
have the topics of dating over 35 also
in groups here is dating advice also in
group 0 social networking and then we
want to pass these back to neo and so we
want to take a quick look at that we
actually see that we we've created a new
relationship here where we've created a
new cluster node and then said okay grab
all the topics that we've we've
determined are within that back cluster
and tie those back this new topic node
and I'll give us a new handle for making
some interesting recommendations so what
does that look like let's match
cluster returned one p so for example we
wanted to see what is this new cluster
we have look like this kind of clusters
here we're talking about that contains
you know singles over 50 dating over 35
and so as a side note about the
visualization tool here in the browser
and get it typically only renders right
under 100 due to 500 nodes and that's
kind of a comfortable limit of what you
know we as users can understand nicely
if you're looking to do more global
visualization there's some some better
JavaScript libraries for that i'm b'fer
actually inspecting our date I think
this is absolutely excellent so we were
double click on the group and say okay
expand me show me a little bit more of
of what's actually attached to that and
we can zoom out a bit and say okay
groups here is actually a pretty pretty
densely connected group and if we were
to actually click on one of these these
topic nodes are you actually one of the
actual groups associated with it
aggressive visualization so for example
the the speed networking topic has the
asian-american Chicago network tied to
it as does the networking insider edge
style Chicago meetup group as well so
back to our handy-dandy browser guide um
oh that's exactly what we just did and
so if we were to look at topic
similarity and I apologize it for some
reason I didn't end up with a lot of
Python groups um I end up simply with
just you know python it in cluster 2 and
unfortunately weren't you know they we
saw earlier there's only one group tied
to that Python node but if we inspect
you know what are the groups there
similar to or there have been been
grouped or the topics have been grouped
with Python wind up with you know the
top of co-founder or women's networking
startup businesses retirement planning I
don't that that's a little bit of quant
stuff but next we hope to expand a
little more now that we have kind of
this basic content filtering of where we
say this group shares a lot of share of
topics with this other group so we know
that they're similar we've now actually
chunked those those those topics
together and said well these topics are
actually all very similar to one another
let's expand a little bit more on
recommendation engine and so we're gonna
one we're nas's we're actually do some
individualization here and say okay
let's exclude the groups that i'm a
member of it's great to leverage the
things i'm already doing in a
recommendation engine obviously we would
like to say the antimatter you don't
recommend me things already own or the
the group's i'm already a member of
actually zoom back up and so let's take
a quick look at kind of this membership
data set so for example we have a
solution an array here on adam krolik of
all the topics that he he's affiliated
with and the group he's he's tied to and
so what we're gonna do is simply do that
Sam load CSV exercise and tie both the
topics that Adam has said hey I'm
interested in whatever 781 is I'm deeply
in love with 15 12 one super interesting
to me as well as the the groups that
he's joined um for example we have a row
here saying that he is joined group you
know group ID you know 1017 seven or two
and then actually the timestamp but when
she joined that group at and we can
actually look at a little more to say
the group's I'm joining today may be
more relevant to the recommendations of
the group's I joined four years ago and
I just haven't cleared out my my meetup
I meet up you know subscription feed so
it's actually one creative uniqueness
constraint here where we don't want
members to be be replicated we're hoping
that we are all unique individuals the
unique preferences and so a quick topic
I want to introduce in terms of
interacting with Nia Jay's load CSV tool
is is periodic commit so cipher will
keep all transactions all transaction
state in memory while running a query
which nine times in 10 is totally fine
but when we're doing really really large
imports and the next one we're about to
do is a couple hundred thousand members
we're going to use something called a
periodic commit and the reason why we do
that is to avoid an out of memory
exception and so if we use the the key
phrase of using periodic commit load CC
we're just going to default 2000 Road
chunks though we can actually pass in a
given value and just you know
anecdotally most of the time between
five thousand to ten thousands kind of
the the happy medium for for performance
there and the next thing I want to talk
about is the with claws and if you
notice so far we've just been doing
fairly isolated queries of you know dou
X dou y what the whisk with claws will
allow us to do is to build query parts
together and chain them together to say
do this interesting traversal fine you
know what was hanging off the end of
this this this pattern grab whatever's
hanging off that and do these other
things with it and allows you to really
extend and write a fairly sophisticated
graph traversal in a hopefully
reasonably easy fashion it can be used
to limit the number of entries that are
passed into other match clauses for
example if I you know I said hey
grabbing arbitrary hundred members out
of the meetup dataset and I'd only like
to operate on though
those hundred users we use a whiff
clause to say you know match me some
users limit that to 100 we and filter on
aggregate values and we can separate
reading from updating the graph for
efficiency's sake though now that we
have a cost-based execution planner that
is not as imperative but it's still good
practice um any questions so far no um
so we're going to go ahead and load this
data in and so to inspect this this
query a little more we're saying using
periodic commit 10,000 as we discussed a
little earlier same call load CSV with
headers you know this the CSV has has
headers that we're going to be using to
choose what values to grab we're
providing at a location and then we're
saying with distinct row ID as ID grab
the the name property under the row and
just alias that is named and we're going
to do is simply emerged yet again this
is a arbitrary identifier this could be
M when you create a new member that way
merge some member meaning create a node
that is is that it's labeled member with
a property called ID which we've grabbed
from that ID header within our CSV oh
and I did that twice cancel whoops and
so we'd like to do is connect my resume
and by the way actually if we're to go
back and try that again because we added
that uniqueness constraint nothing will
happen because it'll just say oh you
know we've already created that so you
know sorry good luck we've we've
essentially we've enforced that we can't
double create a a member so CI no no
changes now rose and so now we're going
to do is connect these these members and
so we're going to say you know one read
back through that this member CSV and if
you remember earlier we had that that
group ID
header and through say match me the
member that we just created match who
they grow the group that we've already
also created but we're just grabbing
that ID out of that header column and
we're saying merge meaning ensure that
this pattern exists within our database
that this member now has a new
relationship called member of with a
direction to that this group that we
just found and then on create set
meaning so if you are making this new
relationship go ahead and add this
additional property and so we're saying
is create a new property called joined
on that relationship and we're going to
grab it from the value from that that
joined header with our CSV and so a
thing to note here is we're doing a bit
of a string operation because New York
Jay's load CSV tool will interpret
everything as a string and stuff that
will have to do is cajole it in some
fashion as they all you know to end to
float etc actually let's let's take a
look at our current data set so as we're
sewing all these things together lots of
members lots of groups let's see if
we've got new and done yet okay so what
we're doing is so Scott the Scott the
drummer missed a member of the the get
off the couch group as is Robert Harris
and Rec helm and Patti etc and Sabine
start to see oh you know if lots of
these users are also members of the same
groups maybe they already friends and we
actually use that to create you know
that some sort of synthetic friendship
relationship or knows relationship or if
they're co members of a lot of the same
groups we then look at the Deltan say oh
you know Scott and Rick are both members
of you know 25 of the same groups but
Scott's a member of two others that Rick
is it maybe we should recommend those to
him still learning and so let's also add
some additional indexes where because
we're going to be wanting to grab on to
members based on their names
and so I assumed since you guys all know
if lots about meetups that you may be a
part of some of these groups so you can
go and try and find yourself within
these groups don't want to give me their
name will try it and do no no one all
right fine I planned for this um so some
of you guys may know max de Mars e is
Annie afraid neo4j engineer that up
until recently lived in Chicago so I
will be abusing him for the rest of this
demo and so here's Mack so we're saying
you match me some member where they have
a name that is a string called max to
marzi so here's max hi max and so we may
want to say okay what are what are the
relationship or what are the groups that
Max is a member of turn em let's go to
given identifier so it seems like Max
not is no longer you know incredibly
active in the in the Chicago meetup
community and so is only a member of the
hacker nice Chicago group and the boots
trappers breakfast and so a thing to
note here is that there are two ways to
to identify properties on a given node
for for the filtering steps so you can
do you know match some member with curly
brace and the properties that we wanted
to operate on or it says to filter on
and so I mean these would have the exact
same output as before or we can simply
do it you know where predicate here and
say you know where m dot name etc
and so as we saw earlier from from our
last query Max is lame he's only a
member of two groups and so let's
actually look a little deeper into it
and say well what are the groups that
are or what are the topics that those
groups are affiliated with to start your
kind of building this this
recommendation query slowly so we're
saying you know match me max them and
the group's he's a member of and then of
those groups grab the topics that those
groups are affiliated with and so now we
see that hacker news Chicago is tied to
Ruby and hacking and Django and boost
rappers breakfast is tied to start up
businesses and and all this this
entrepreneurship peer to peer advisory
etc and so then you know we're going to
take another step out and say okay we
grabbed all the groups that Max as a
member of other topics that those groups
are affiliated with and actually look at
the number of clusters that those those
groups are tied to and i'd be willing to
guess that they're they're probably all
tied to the same same clusters and so if
you notice here we've just simply just
thrown a comment here to create a more
complex pattern and so we're just still
referring to these same identifiers so
this group is the same group here I'm
saying a member of group group has topic
topic as cluster and then count the
number of clusters that these these
groups you're tied to so yeah his his
topics are tied to cluster number 2 25
times and then cluster 0 once I'm
actually let's let's try some other
people um match
number turn name skip arbitrary number
143 return let's grab two random people
out of our data set and see what they're
tied to I'm so we have a you know Anita
Johnson so let's see what we're if she's
tied to or what topics she's tied to oh
she's really interested in cluster zero
which if you guys remember earlier was
the it kind of be the dating and social
networking cluster and then a rickety
Anderson um see what she's interested in
Fisher curios she's super active over
that's awesome we're gonna use her for
the rest of this demo oh cool I'm going
to try and finance editor thank you so
she's tied to many different clusters
she's tied to tons of groups it seems
like so she's tied to cluster 03 hundred
eighty five times prep probably pretty
social i'm sure i muster to was though
that was tied to a lot of the developer
and engineering groups and as well as a
good deal of others cool awesome Thank
You Rica and so let's let's go further
down this rabbit hole and actually start
doing some some sorting and filtering um
so let's actually grab these these
topics actually look at look at them a
little more deeply that's little the
last thing we just did come on let's
just exclude the groups that Arica is a
member of and so we want to find groups
that are similar to outdoorsy adventure
club so I can't remember the name of it
we're going to do this and group dot
name uh starts with I do it was outdoors
you right
so groups they're similar to this ad or
Z group that sure some topics were the
things that are eek is interested in so
we may want to recommend her to join the
get out and do it adventure and social
meetup group and so where you might be
using this this recommendation query
would be if she's you know Traverse to
the outdoorsy entrepreneurship page and
we want to look at other things that
might be relevant to both this you know
expressed intent here by navigating to
the page but as well as the other things
we know about her and so this is kind of
the the shape of the the recommendation
we're starting to look at of so by by
navigating to a topic I've expressed
interest in it and you're may have even
clicked on the page and said oh yeah
interesting and so I'm also the member
of a group and we're looking for these
these shared topics as well as these
these these these shared clusters and so
we're going to do this this find my
similar groups again so we're grab arica
and so to kind of dissect this you know
messy long traversal we're simply saying
start etta at that index node right
remember as we talked about find where
were going to be starting in our graph
grab you know this member by by her name
grab the the groups use a member of grab
the topics that those groups are
affiliated with and then grab the other
groups that share that topic and where
she's not already a member of that that
other group that we're recommending and
then essentially ordered these by the
number of topics and comio most similar
to her current portfolio of groups and
so based on all the things she's
expressed some sort of interested by
joining membership groups we would
recommend to her hey Dean go join the do
what you love Chicago singles meetup
group live.laugh.love travel it's great
things for her to do Center an email
later but hey we figured out what you
want um
and so I actually we moved our hair done
this part where we actually grab some
who is tied to lots of different meetup
groups and seeing how they change for
example if we were to do this with with
Max I imagine these would be much less
interesting recommendations I'm actually
not bad so we end up with product on
Chicago should our formula answers
meetup things that kind of seem to be in
his cachet of interest and so now let's
do some some event recommendations kind
of if you guys remember from the slides
earlier where we were looking at kind of
these two here we're looking at one kind
of these email pings just hey you might
be interested in going to this event no
we know it's you know everything on your
calendar and you know it's is when
you're your time frame of typical
attendance or be looking at just simply
as I'm browsing through the the meetup
com calendar and they say oh these are
the events at six thirty seven o'clock
and so forth that you might be
interested in so we're actually going to
want to grab the events that these these
groups are hosting so we're doing is we
have okay one when is the event we
actually have a little little status
property here just say look what are the
previous events that they've had or is
this an upcoming event and also what
group are they tied to its we're going
to go and load these in you guys should
be be pros of this now we're we're
asserting one you know the event ID is
unique to we're going to create an index
on event time because when be searching
on it quite a bit so let's go and import
those we're going to go and use that
same periodic commit that we talked
about earlier we're grabbing a whole
different CSV now called the event CSV
we're going to merge these events and
since you ensure that these events exist
based on these IDs and if we had if we
figure out that we haven't already
created this node when we do I'm grab
all these other values from from
row that in our NRCS fee and so let's
actually take a quick look at that um so
to ensure things are imported correctly
again we noticed we end up with just
islands of nodes we double-click nothing
expands and the reason why we do this is
kind of as a general best practice it
allows you to at a much higher fidelity
if no meteor hits your data center and
during an import near for Jay's load CSV
is a transactional import such that if
something were to explode it would say
oh yeah we're committed to this point
you know they're no partial commits this
is where we're at and if you're doing it
based on this this merge command you
Center you can just trickle down to okay
that's where the data center exploded or
if you're you're doing the ensure that a
relationship exists again it's much much
easier to figure out okay this is the
intermediate step that we were at and so
let's go ahead and tie this all together
and so to take another look at this
we're going to grab you two distinct
group IDs we're going to grab the the
row IDs via these are the ideas of the
groups that were or the events that
we're looking at based on the group ID
and the event ID find those things that
already exist with our database and with
those two groups go and ensure that
there is a relationship between the
group and the group and the event
they're hosting and we'll just call
hosted event um so just to generically
look at it snow neo4j here outdoors so
here the events hosted by the the
outdoorsy group they hosted yoga for
your workday [ __ ] that's kind of their
things is hosting yoga for your workday
I'm some sort of summer rooftop event
and so we're actually so if we're
looking at simply the the groups were
already affiliate
did with and so we wanted to see for
arica what are the future events that
maybe be relevant for her to tend kind
of these basic foundations of saying hey
these are the things you've already
expressed interest in what we're doing
here saying okay grab her grab her
groups and grab the events that those
groups are hosting where the time at
which the event occurs is you know
greater than this moment right now and
simply just returning the group names
the name of the the event and then this
is what we're doing here is something a
little bit of math to figure out how
many days out that is it zeroed is it
today is it 1 2 3 X days out and order
by the the events that are happening
today and then work out from there so
things that are happening tomorrow for
tomorrow at the time we scrape this
there is you know there must be this
place with Joe McMahon make mahaan free
beer and comedy etc and so this is be
kind of our initial recommendation to
her as she hit her her meetup com page
we're going to hey you know free Chicago
Vance's how is having these two two
events right now you've already directly
expressed interest by joining these
groups but we're gonna be a little sly
that will add a little more so let's
actually look at future events based on
on the topix she's expressed interest in
so we're saying here is going to go
ahead and grab arica again grab these
future events that we've just just
grabbed um and so what we're simply
doing is ensure that these events are
part of the groups that she's joined on
similar to that exist keyword is we're
matching that pattern and they were say
an optional match that it these things
that she's expressed interest in and
that these events share those topics or
that these groups share those topics
that host these events and so hopefully
this point you guys are starting to see
that recommend
stations are inherently very very graphi
or looking at several steps out to make
a simple you know go to this event
recommendation and so we're gonna say
you know without these things we've
identifying these topics that we we've
identified grab these these future
events and then go and return them
ordered by which events are happening
soonest ricas got a lot of events my
poor laptop
sorry
so let's try that again subscribe max
because he has significantly fewer
events I may have broken something Oh
arch there we go so for Rico we have
kind of future events based on the
common topics that exist from that
within her network it's interesting that
they primarily share one one common
topic and so these are groups that she's
not already associated with but events
they're very similar to those that she
has already expressed it very similar to
the groups in which she's expressed
interest in going to so we might
recommend these and saying okay here
through the vents within your catalog of
groups but if you wanted to branch out
fun to new events to go to these are the
things that may be relevant to you and
so to just kind of put into your court
maybe try and go ahead and show if you
guys are coding along the events that
are happening the next seven days and
then also show events it happen for the
topics in my top cluster
and so um actually it's good it's going
to answer those together
so if we extend the we extend the query
we just ran we can actually say okay
we're
we're going ahead and grab and be a
friend group
days
oops
cool and so the events happening in the
next seven days for her are simply these
and so simply all we did was take the
number of days outgoing we've moved that
up into with statement aliased it as as
a as days and simply just did some a
little bit of a less than and said okay
well four days less than seven until
they return those events and then we
continue to order them by the things
that are happening about more recently
and so this is kind of a the mack daddy
query this this is what we would
actually end up trying to deploy and so
I'll try and walk walk through this
reasonably slowly but so the goal is to
create an aggregate recommendation we're
saying here the events that are coming
up in your in your groups and these are
all so we're going to insert within
those results events that are in groups
that are similar to those that you've
already joined but we'd actually like to
wait those based on if you've already
said I I'm a part of this group I like
going to their events we'll give that a
higher weight and if if not we'll just
kind of give it a genetic or zero and so
the query we just executed what we're
saying you know match me you know give a
member let's give it let's grub max
again match some event we're calling it
future event where it's happening soon
where centuries happening beyond today
we're going to then say ensure that one
if you've noticed were actually grouping
together these three recommendation
queries we've done earlier or ensuring
that one I am a member of these current
groups for the the my group events were
grabbing and there were optionally
matching events that they may be hosting
and then we're say okay for those of the
two common topics we use this for our
similarity
and then we'll say okay well let's also
grab those events better hosted by
groups that I'm not necessarily part of
and then if it's part of my group we're
going to go ahead and give it a a plus 5
and if not we'll just give it a zero
answer then where we're going to go
ahead and in return our aggregate query
Oh max there's no future events from
let's try Rica it's routine
Oh
there we go
All Right see what's coming up for her
we can recommend 0 because this is we
hold data
oh the demo God's just like me
here yeah sorry the browser's really
hates being zoomed in
say going forward something that the
real lesson here is I should have this
on live data oh it's still well guys on
that note apparently I'm going to throw
in the towel so this would be the
structure of how we would do this but I
guess the the the lesson learned
especially for me here is using week old
data and then using lots of time stamps
it's not good so just kind of walk
through it again we're simply trying to
look for events that are either within
ricas given groups that are coming up
with in with a number of days and B
we're also looking at groups that share
topics with those usually expressed
interest in and grabbing the events that
those are hosting in the next few days
and then essentially up waiting and down
waiting those just say well if youíve
directly expressed interest pushes at
the top of the result set and if you
haven't leave those as a neutral score
cool so I guess any questions um and I'm
going to make this work and please find
me in the hallway and I'll show you guys
cool all right well thanks guys sorry um
sort of really kind of it will come down
to more network density versus the
actual size of the data set I'm sorry so
the question was in terms of scaling
things like collaborative filtering with
neo4j where do you start to bump into
scaling limits and so the answer is that
it's less about the the aggregate size
of the data set so what winning for J
will do is once it's grabbed a note or a
node ID it'll be doing porn arithmetic
or pointer chasing between nodes and so
it's more looking at network density to
say if we have each node is new has a
hundred million relationships um that's
going to hurt you know just it's going
to crush any computer but if you're
still looking at you know an average
density of you know a couple thousand a
couple million you're going to see
pretty reasonable times without regard
to aggregate
you set size and again from